[Applause]  when you taught blocking out and  somebody actually did it  tatum against irving tatum turns fires  connects  jason tatum 42 basketball  and let me take advantage of the size  get a smaller guy and kyrie irving  on me again get the switch that you like  and take advantage of it tatum gets  inside and banks at home  he is unstoppable right now  here's what i'm talking about he's being  defended by kevin durant you don't have  to switch that once you do  everybody out of my way it's time to  dance  gets to his spot elevates and finishes  at the rim that's beautiful offense and  simple  to walker up top tatum  durant the long reach tatum crossover  pull-up jumper  it's good 50 points for jason tatum  it's a seven point lead timeout brooklyn  says that kevin durant allow me to have  this dance  everybody out of my way knocks down the  contested shape